Last year, the I F
P hosted its two day national policy conference
ahead of the national elections
and as a way to put together their
manifesto for the 2024 elections.
And I saw the story
news 24 that talked about how they are going to be
say no to unrestricted Abortion acts
and how they are looking to amend the choice of
termination of Pregnancy Act.
As somebody who has worked in abortion access
activism for the past couple of years,
and somebody
who's just written a book that also focuses on
how evangelical
churches and evangelical movements oppose abortion.
I found the story very worrying for a number of reasons.
There are few things that are in the article
that are concerning,
which the I F
P believes in
the first one being the fact that
they want to stop abortion as a form of contraceptive.
This is a very well known myth
and it's been used by many anti abortion movements.
What the if incorrectly
labels as unrestricted abortion acts,
which I believe is actually quite
deliberate of them to do
is the fact that in 2,005,
the new law came into effect
where registered nurses
and registered midwives were able to also
perform termination
up to 12 weeks of pregnancy.
Instead of looking at this as
improving access to abortion services,
they look at it as unrestricted abortion access.
It seems that they're looking at it
from a point where they see access to abortion as
Something that should not be happening to begin with
and that termination of a pregnancy is inherently a
moral feeling
or something bad that should not happen at all.
The use of myths
such as abortion is being used as contraceptors
is one that can be seen and can be traced back to
evangelical anti abortion movements in the U.
S. And other parts of the west.
No such thing as unrestricted abortion
in South Africa. In fact,
we have a choice of termination of Pregnancy Act that
stipulates in which conditions termination can happen.
And this does not mean it's unrestricted
but the access to termination
in the ways that are stated in the act shows that
South Africa is serious about curtailing maternal
mortality rate
and ensuring that the right of
people who can fall pregnant are protected
and that access to abortion is afforded to anyone
who wants to do it.
Abortion as contraceptives is a well known myth
that is mostly used by religious
anti abortion movements.
And you know that from studies.
It shows that people terminate pregnancies because
the contraceptives have failed
or they did not get
access to contraceptives to begin with
or are terminating the pregnancy
because they were either assaulted
or the sex that
resulted in the pregnancy was due to coercion.
The IFP aims to hold public hearings
to amend the choice of termination of Pregnancy Act
in order to stop this unrestricted abortions.
But we need to remember why we have
The abortion law that we have
to begin with,
at the onset of democracy in South Africa,
one of the first areas
that the department of health tackled
was the high rate of maternal mortality
that were happening in South Africa.
And most of them were as a result of
women and people who are pregnant
seeking abortion services
from unsafe abortion providers,
which were illegal at the time
and still are. The I F.
P is not the only party that has tried to curtail
access to abortion in South Africa.
In fact, the African Democratic Christian Party,
the a C d. P
has been one of
the most vocal voices that has been against abortion
in Parliament.
Elementary records show that
even before
the amendments that were made in 2,005,
the original choice of
termination of Pregnancy Act
was challenged by parties
such as the African Democratic Christian Party,
the a C d. P,
who has opposed
any access to abortion in democratic South Africa
every time they've gotten a chance to do so.
Besides terminating a pregnancy,
saving the lives of many,
many people who are pregnant,
it also really is a human right
and we shouldn't fight it in any way whatsoever.
For a party that was founded on ethno
nationalism
to now use religious doctrine
and evangelical
anti abortion movement rhetoric
to really try to curtail the rights of women
and people who fall pregnant
is very telling
in the atmosphere that we are in
in South Africa.
Access, determination of pregnancy.
Still needs to become more Liberal in South Africa
and the access needs to be more widespread,
particularly in rural areas
where there is
often struggles.
And for a party
such as the I F
P or even the a C,
d. P. To try and curtail those rights
is very telling
and is a very concerning matter.
It's concerning for me
to see so much of the evangelical
anti abortion movement rhetoric
find ground in South Africa,
particularly
as we go into the elections,
because we do know that
even though we are a so called
circular state,
we have very,
very religious,
moral and cultural
attitudes towards certain things,
abortion included.
But we need to remember that
abortion saves lives.